you're friends with Jerry Seinfeld yeah  I'm told that when Seinfeld first met  you you were in a room full of people  and he knew yes he knew who you were but  he didn't he didn't know what you looked  like he just knew that you were the  comic out in a room full of people crazy  crazy he just walks in the room and ten  people in the room and he looked at me  point like that you're the funny guy I'm  like yeah but how do you know did you  google me no and how do you know I know  who's funny in this room but I didn't  say anything that was just standing  you're the funny guy I say yes it's  scary yeah I'd be scary that he'd walk  into a room and he wouldn't point to me  no that's the funny guy not that one the  other one you mean me no the other one  the one that's that's the caterer yeah  sometimes the caterers the funniest  wanting yeah you never know funnier